hello everyone David and Karen of film
courage here we are on the line with
Lucas McNally Lucas McNally is the
filmmaker whose year without rent
campaign took the indie film world by
storm where he raised over twelve
thousand dollars eight thousand of which
in the last 24 hours of the campaign the
year without rent project entails Lucas
traveling across country to volunteer
his time on various indie film sets and
we are pleased to speak with him thank
you for joining us Lucas oh my pleasure
yeah this is great the sort of sort of
connect with you you're currently in san
francisco is that right yeah i am
somewhere in san francisco i have no
idea where in the kitchen can you give
us an idea all the productions you've
worked on i mean when did you begin i
actually going out and taking part in
these productions was it was that it was
that around it mid-february mid-february
either the 17th or the 18th we kind of
lost track which day we started okay and
right now we're on it's May
twenty-fourth 2011 so how many
productions can you show to estimate how
many you've been involved with so far
between productions and like events like
a go-fast stuff like that ah it's gotta
be over 20 by now I would think it's
somewhere there i was gonna figure it
out um before i got on the phone forgot
on skype with you because I knew you
would ask me that and I'm totally forgot
and I'm wondering of these productions
have there been any where you haven't
quite fit in or you weren't really
needed and if so how did you handle that
um there's been some run needed less
than others you know you can always use
somebody to carry a c-stand and help
unload the truck faster or load the
truck up faster or whatever and so the
more I needed the fewer photos I take
and the less video I do because um doing
stuff into carrying stuff and whatever
and there's been a couple projects where
they just wanted me they just had me on
to do video and photo like ego fest uh
Phil homework basically just wanted me
to do that sort of thing so yeah I mean
I don't think I've had anywhere
didn't spit in I its trick it's always
tricky the first day when you come into
a production because everyone's kind of
if you come in halfway through
everyone's already got their momentum
and they're working relationships and
whatnot figured out so like on
nor'easter the very first I got there
near the end of one of the days and the
first one first questions I got asked
from one of the grips was if I'd ever
been on a film set before I said yeah
couple here there so there's always that
sort of fur process of figuring that out
you know and mmm as am I don't I mean
you're coming in to to these sites I
mean I don't I guess I'm not just
getting exposed on expand on the same
thing I mean so for the most part of me
to have they been pretty welcoming to
having you inside oh yeah everyone's
been really accommodating and really
welcoming um they're happy to have help
for the most part they're a little
worried about what I might write or what
I might say about the production and
every single production asked me if all
the other productions are as
disorganized as theirs is as the
question I get every single time they
always or they go well how do we compare
are we cooler then the other productions
or the other coaches cooler than us and
so that's kind of interesting a sense of
competition a little bit it's a little
bit of book yeah there's a little bit of
a sense of competition or just I think
people just want to see how because they
do their thing you know over and
Hartford or wherever they want to see
how what they do in Hartford compares to
what people are doing in Minnesota or
Seattle or something so do you find that
is some K in some instances like they're
almost rolling out the red carpet for
you to sort to sort of like schmooze and
sway you in a certain direction um so
that you'll write more favorable you
have no more favorable things about what
they're doing I mean maybe a little but
i think that doesn't last very long
because then people get really
overwhelmed with how much work they have
to do and then they just kind of forget
on there and then i'll just starts
ticking cameras in their basement you
know there's that first day the first
time used a Cameron's once pasted on top
no not me not me and then they get they
just get used to it and ignore you and
of the filmmakers or the different
people on the set how many of them are
aware of what you're doing versus those
who owe hadn't heard about it like how
well-known is this across these sets
that you're on the directors all know
obviously because that's usually going
to talk to before I even got there and
most of those people are people who
already knew about the project before
before I got in contact with them or
they got in contact with me or whatever
usually the grips who don't know what
the hell is going on or who this person
is and they usually wants don't care um
and actors actors sometimes no I've
heard about it and sometimes but usually
have it but they're usually the most
interested because they figured they're
gonna get the most publicity after this
you know before I forget I know you had
a very interesting observation about the
filmmakers who are on social media you
know and sort of come together they are
as opposed to the ones that aren't on
social media and really seem to be
disorganized can you just sort of share
your thoughts on that force um yeah i
mean i have a bunch of cancellations and
very few of them come from people who
are socially media active because i
think there's you know if you're if you
make a film in a vacuum if your phone
gets cancelled or delayed or reschedule
or whatever no one really cares other
than you and your cast and crew but if
you have a thousand people following you
on twitter and you're telling everybody
about this book we're going to make them
in the film doesn't get made you know
it's kind of little bit of a peer
pressure thing and you know nobody wants
to do that which is the whole idea with
weight loss things where they say to
tell everybody how much but wait you're
trying to lose so then you'll be
motivated to keep doing it um so I think
there's maybe more incentive to find a
way to salvage a project when it falls
apart because every project falls apart
at some point yeah you know you guys are
filmmakers use it is the filmmaker has
another project fall apart on them is a
liar
yes no you know you know on our side
we're just sort of we just continue to
push our way through the post-production
process on goodbye balama so yeah you
know that it almost it feels like at
every step along the way you know don't
you surprised yeah there's a new
surprise and it is in his trial fall
apart on you and you have to continue to
do all you can to keep it together when
we were filming upcountry it fell apart
between when we raise the money on
Kickstarter and the start of shooting it
fell apart I think three times and that
was a month in between those two Tate's
so it mean it happens and then you just
have to figure out you have to figure
out a way around it because those are
the people who the people I think who
who survived in indie film or not the
people who are that much talent more
talented than everybody I think there's
more stubborn than everybody else you
know and they're just like well we don't
have a back-up plan for this year so I
have to make movies so I'm going to make
movie and however that's going to end up
happening is how it ends up happening
and I sticking with sort of the
production's you've been on I'm curious
what what are the cameras that these
productions are using you know because
you know here you are you're sort of man
you know you're on the forefront of any
productions across the u.s. are you
seeing a lot of a lot of the red camera
are you seeing a lot of the DSLR is
there one camera that stands out it's a
lot of red and it's a lot of DSLR it's
either it seems to either be the red or
the 5d or 270 are mostly what I'm seeing
and you know they'll have another
regular couple extra lenses floating
around depending on their budget and how
many they could get their hands on for
how much but it seems to be a lot of red
DSLRs ok and how large are the crews
that you're working with the biggest
crew was probably 10 crew members total
maybe 15 something like that Madison
Tomlin's project had a kind of a
rotating crew because and so he'd had
people come in for a little bit and then
go out so it was hard to really gauge
how many people he had work
on that and he had a big cast on one day
where he had like I don't know 10 to 15
extras doing dancing doing all sorts of
dancing stuff so that was kind of big
and scale in some ways a nor'easter was
kind of big in scale in terms of the
crew and everything but we're also out
on island off the coast of Maine so I
got the impression that got as many
people as I can convince to come out to
Maine in February you know I guess
overall but it does sound like you're
working in an intimate environments on
these productions you know that you know
yeah 15 people yeah me crew yeah it's
it's the pretty small crew but I mean at
the budget levels I imagine that's about
work starts to become cumbersome is
around 15 people you know and if you're
shooting for two weeks or whatever then
that's just what happens I guess I mean
I'm kind of curious i think i'm gonna be
down in LA for favor and i'm really
curious to see how big a recruit paul
osborne has nice because something tells
me he knows everybody it's a help yeah
yeah interesting um you know it from
like a directing standpoint no here you
are you have a chance to be side-by-side
with directors you get a chance to be on
all these film sets so it sort of what
are you picking up I mean how is this
sort of impacting you know the scope of
how you look at it you know and maybe
moving forward once you come back to
your own production can you can you kind
of just give us some some things that
you're learning along the way here yeah
I'm stealing stuff from people like
every day which is nice because i just
did then i watched somebody and I
watched you know chrisandlindy boosted
on summer home and I see how how they're
interacting with their actors out there
acting with their DP I think that's a
lot of what you pick up is how the
directors manage a set and how they
manage my cast and crew and everyone
does it a little differently like Matson
Tomlin for example would go around every
couple hours to pretty much everybody
and ask them how they were doing and if
they needed anything and you don't get
that a lot
from a director you know um and you sort
of get a sense you sort of get a sense
of what works and what doesn't work in
terms of approaches with people and I
mean that's what directing is it's
managing people in anyone can do a
storyboard and figure out what the shot
list should be can you give us some
specific examples in terms of what what
to do what not to do anything that comes
to mind um I think the big thing to do
is just to listen to people you know I
think the directors that don't do well
are the ones that have their comment on
tourists but there's you have your
vision and then your vision is is gospel
and nothing else can happen in that
vision those don't seem to work very
well but the ones were there actively
soliciting opinion input or whatever
from the DP or from the actors or from
whoever else you know I think those are
the projects that seem to run the most
smoothly because they're able to take
that that that stuff and work it into
their vision so I don't think they lose
the auteur stuff but they're able to
make it a stronger piece overall so the
ones that are flexible in terms of the
feedback and they don't put up a wall so
much yeah you got to be flexible with
feedback and because something's gonna
go wrong it be flexible in terms of
fixing that you know we shot some of
them no one had seen the location before
other than the actress and so they she
would describe it to them and they would
all figure out what they were going to
do based on that and they got there it
was like oh this is not how I pictured
this at all and so then it was a real
all hands on deck how do we shoot this
you know how do we figure out the best
rate word what's our what's our new shot
list and what's our new thing and have
what we use what's here now of most of
the production's you've been on they've
all been out of the LA new york metro
areas so sometimes people question the
talent that comes from outside those two
places what's your take on this what
have you seen I've seen a lot of talent
I mean some of them was from New York in
LA
just people that were imported um but
you know there's seem to be a lot of
talented people in Seattle I saw the DP
and Seattle time ago de was really
talented and I think he's I mean I don't
really even know how much he's done but
he did stuff like he was hand-holding
filters over because they didn't have a
matte box and he was hand-holding them
over part of the frame which was kind of
crazy ridiculous um nor'easter was all
New York people who would come up to
Maine but the cast's have been really
pretty strong and they've come from
pretty much everywhere so I don't I
don't know that it's necessarily that
you're really good talent has to be in
New York in LA I mean it might be but I
remember talking to someone and saying
like just from Lyme filmmaking
experience I've never done a SAG film
because I've never had a situation in
casting where a SAG actor has been
better than an on-site actor you know
and that's just talent is talent and
sometimes it's in LA and sometimes it's
in Boise Idaho you know and some people
want to live in boise idaho because i
hear the driving in LA is terrible you
know I guess you're going to experience
this pretty soon find out yeah and I'm
wondering too how is this last six
months been for you in terms of your
newfound celebrity what are some of the
new realizations that you've come to
about success haters versus the
supporters oh yeah we had some haters
and people don't like me now I'm not
really sure why because sherry candler
told me not to read it but I kept
getting the second or third-hand version
of it wherever I would go somewhere
we're gonna be like oh what's with all
these people who don't like you what's
going on battle and I don't know um you
know I think it's I don't think of
myself as a celebrity's I mean maybe I
have a little more of a target on my
back and maybe I get retweeted more um I
think I got recognized at a film
festival which was kind of weird which
is the value of wearing red sox hat
everywhere i guess but i was able to
sneak into a film festival based on
my so-called celebrity so that was kind
of fun hey wait so which film festival
was that that you snow is seattle
international oh all right so tell us
the story cuz you know cuz ya we
understand I have one of bracelets right
here bracelet on but wait I tell us the
story because somehow you might say film
courage and you end up getting into the
yeah like carpet event or something like
that yes maybe you guys are famous I
think that's the lesson for this story
um so Philip saws in Seattle and Phil
senator said hey if you're going to be
in town long enough for the red gala you
should come to the right gal I can get
you a ticket so don't you know worry
about I went okay great so then the day
rolls around and I can't get Phil on the
phone at all I can't get him on Twitter
I can't get him on the phone I can't
text him nothing so I'm like well
alright so I look up the thing now I'll
just go down there or find him because
he's not going to not go and I remember
can say something about his tickets for
a will call so I go and I can't find it
I find time ago to the GP from the
summer home I fine chrisandlindy was
dead eventually but i can't find bill so
I go over to I find someone who works in
her and I say hey I'm supposed to have a
ticket Olga blah and I write for film
courage a lot and they sort of passed me
up the line of people who knew things I
pull out my phone I'm like no no look I
really do I write I write for one of
your media partners and they gave me a
ticket and gave me drink tickets then I
found Phil inside who was apparently
working I i like i like how they not
only give you tickets but they gave you
drink tickets yeah who drink and then
Phil and I snuck into the VIP section
during we didn't watch the film because
we're filmmakers and there was a free
bar so we went directly to the bar hung
out there during the film met lots of
cool people and drunk drank for free I
need not to use my great chicken I can
still have it and I don't want to spend
too much time on the haters but I just
want to go back to something just real
quick and that isn't of your experience
how much do you think that people don't
think that what you're doing is worth
anything versus they wish they'd done it
and it's more of their own
eternal thing and they put it out onto
you you know I think it's probably they
wish they were doing something because
it's really easy to have time to do that
if you're not doing anything right um no
one I know who's really working who's
actively doing projects has time to
create fake identities online and and
fight with people it's just but you know
I guess I don't know maybe it's
starbucks during your break you can do
that I'm not sure I'm not sure what you
know right there to do is um but you
know I have a motto where if I get not
really motto but I don't listen to
anybody who doesn't put their real
identity on it and I don't care if its
complementary or not um because if you
don't have enough courage I guess or
enough you don't believe enough and what
you're saying to put your reputation
behind it then it's not worth anything
it's not worth your time to read or
someone else's time to read or respond
to or anything that I mean they are fun
to make fun of them and Dave and I were
talking yesterday about a situation
where we needed to tie up some loose
ends with an individual and we both
looked at each other and we're like you
know what this comes back to Lucas
mcnellies post filmmakers get your stuff
together yes I'm cleaning it up a little
bit sure ma'am where did that develop
from that thing about filmmakers not
having their stuff together and why do
you think that is I think it's you know
I think it goes back to when you watch
bad indie films they're always badly
written because nobody wants troops bend
due to extra drafts of a film of a
script because that's boring everybody
wants to be on set and they want to be
filming and so I think the danger is a
lot of times we kind of gloss over some
of that other stuff and I do it too in
order to get into production because
that's the fun part and so we're not
real worried about the random crap that
you have to put together in order to get
your film off the ground
um but I mean part of it is just I think
people don't think of it they think
because there are an artist they can
just sort of be la-dee-da whatever and
they don't look at it like like a
business or like being in middle
management because it's is effectively
what it is is being a middle management
you gotta deal with all these people and
it's all this crap goes on um yeah I
don't know I just people the article
came from having a ton of cancellations
in a row and and then one filmmaker who
I'm not sure I should name but I had
lined him up his life he was like our
plans see for a week for one of the
scheduled dates and he was in Tampa and
so I'd fly to Tampa and I was in
Pennsylvania because I'm just enough
time to drive it so I said to unless
like hey wanna fly I need a couch to
crash on and I need someone to get me at
the airport because I don't you know
anybody in Tampa he said oh ok Michael
do that we might not um I'll get back to
you and I said okay well great because I
have the plane tickets thing up and just
tell me which plane to get a ticket for
I'll get a ticket for that plane and I
have not heard a word from themselves
and so I was kind of in limbo for three
or four days going well maybes busy and
whatnot now I seem on facebook and dumb
production I guess he's alive I know
that I'm just like this is ridiculous I
mean this is not a question of you know
be a good filmmaker being a bad tool
maker this is just like common decency
of letting someone know what's going on
to some extent you know and I mean we
all do it but to we're gonna do it a
little bit i'm sure i've done it and
someone's probably to come on here and
talk about how a horrible person I am
because I left them hanging once but you
know it's it's it's whence almost trying
to come help you on your project no call
it back on a budgetary level I mean how
are you doing with with the money that
you raised you know are you know you
still have reserves in the tank there
and and and since sort of the conclusion
your Kickstarter campaign have you been
able to sort of expand on that budget
have you been able to raise money in any
kind of way we've been trying to we've
been having a little trouble um I have a
producer Pittsburgh crews working on
sponsorships and I think she has one
lined up and his trying has her the
irons or a bunch of different fires um
the budgets holding up pretty well as
long as I can get somewhere I don't
spend any money because I just need
crash services and I sleep on couches so
really the costs are the travel um it's
the cancellations end up getting
expensive because then I have to spin my
wheels for a week or four or five days
or whatever to get somewhere but we're
very actively looking for more funding
because it's just you know twelve
thousand dollars minus the Kickstarter
fees yeah or not not really a lot of
money which is what makes the haters
comments so funny when they're like
always told all this money for all these
people and blah blah blah you know it's
it's a pretty small budget if you think
about spending a year traveling and
gasping for something a gallon and here
you are you're showing up on set
volunteering is he a set photographer or
what have you and now we understand that
you've received a few things in front of
the camera where they would she was sort
of cameo appearances yeah I'm in a game
over um I play I played a customer who
curses and somebody which is really my
specialty if you need me when I I salute
theatre program I would help with I
would help with a lot of plays and
because I wanted to sort of get to know
how actors worked and what not I'm not
an actor at all but if you need someone
to walk on stage do a string of
profanity at a character or the audience
and then leave that I'm your guy I'm
really good at that um so I end up
showing up in the background of things
sometimes I'm you know you need an extra
or whatnot and I try to wear a shirt
from somebody else and you film when I
do end up in the background so hopefully
if I can I don't want my Gregory bate
sure what but it's I try to
sort of working a promo with it if I
possibly can well what would you say to
actors in terms of doing that like using
that as a side way to get your foot in
the door instead of going that
traditional route and oh I have to be
paid and all of that I think you know
you really have to have a resume to get
paid and you really especially as an
actor like if you haven't shown that you
if you have been in a couple of
different things that were you've been
really good and you're asking to Peyton
on any film or probably nobody's getting
paid you're stuck in the cast because
the thing about actors is there's a lot
of them and there's a lot of talented
actors and you can rewrite a script to
fit an actor it's not very hard um so
you mean my motto with actors is if
actors are difficult or that it looks
like they're going to be difficult in
any way shape or form eyes get somebody
else so you know I mean we're all
working for free on some level and you
know at least for a little bit so it may
be it's harder in LA I don't know but I
would think would be easier because
there's more actors I mean you can't get
go into a store without running into an
actor right yeah I mean if you know how
to cast then I mean you can always
replace an act with a non-actor not they
hate that you can stealth Imperial plays
ohms and they find you know they find
ways around their problem sometimes look
is something to sort of went over our
heads is that you know with your with
our rent I guess you're actually you've
actually been there's a part of this
where it's actually a feature
documentary you know it what at what
point did that come into play well um
the thing is there isn't officially a
future documentary on IMDb wouldn't let
us wouldn't accept us as a web series
and everyone was really can some people
thought it was a feature documentary
even though I never said it was and so
we just submitted a time to be as a
feature documentary thinking we could
surely get in and get the IMDB page up
and so now there's
talk I have an idea for the future
documentaries now everybody seemed to
think there is one so i might as well we
might will do one um the idea I have is
but I think it would be interesting to
give at the end of the year give all the
footage to another filmmaker to a
documentary filmmaker and say to sort of
handle all the footage and say or her
own foot and say I want you to take a
critical look at the project and the
year without rent and try to determine
whether or not it was success or failure
or whatnot and be completely honest and
for me to just sort of back off it and
say you know I'll be available for if
you need me to interview if you need you
know someone's contact information and
then other than that let me know what
it's not because I think it would be you
know to sort of take a step back from it
and sort of get perspective from someone
who wasn't right there in it all the
time would be probably I think more
interesting and more helpful to people
because otherwise if i make it will end
up being even if I try not to be they'll
end up being in support of the project
whereas somebody else could take a
critical look at it and really figure
out what it was what the success in the
failures were so what if they turn it
into overnight they turn into what
overnight the documents diamonds number
oh you haven't seen overnight okay I
never see anything I'm in my car or a
lot of set oh you know we hear you know
we have we often have our our time
keeping up ourselves but so yeah me so
that means this documentary is yet yet
to be determined so it's known or finir
I mean have you thought about sort of at
what point are you gonna put it out
there and say hey are there any sort of
um you know how documentary editors or
well that idea kind of is new it kind of
I just sort of Ravana batting around few
people that uh I'm just you know sperm
randomly talking to it everyone's him to
like the idea and I think they like that
it's not it's not you know a big
cheering section thing for the project
um so then it just becomes a question of
finding somebody who's not involved in
the project
ready in some which eliminates quite a
few people and then just somebody who we
think would be willing to do it and able
to do it so we'll probably start looking
around at some point now we think it's
an excellent idea you know it's a it's a
great way to sort of tie this together
mmm and as I told Marty lot as Marty
line and I were talking about it he said
I imagine at the end of the year you
were probably not going to want to look
at that footage for a very long time
you're probably going to be kind of over
it at that point and you're not going to
want to spend another year like ending
it into a feature documentary and I was
like yeah that sounds about right yeah
the other joke is that i'll end up i'll
go in a room at the end of this for a
month I will not leave that room and so
it'll go do you want to drive downtown
to meet me to have a drink no no no I do
not you can bring the drinks here I'm
they're not getting in a car no chance
you know and I mean will be crucial to
that is just capturing all those moments
all the all the highs all the lows I
mean do you feel like you are capturing
that sort of material you know with
yourself in with others oh yeah you
always think you can capture more but i
think i'm capturing a decent amount of
good stuff um the one thing I might
start doing with this new idea is
because we might not find a filling dirt
under the end is start getting like the
Lakers are going to have them interview
me maybe so at least then there's
interview footage from along the path
yeah yeah things like that you know if
you need this little recording here just
this let us know ok just to come just
capturing a moment in time here yeah and
this would maybe be a good thing to use
although the video quality might not be
great for blowing it out we're gonna
have to find a way to manipulate that
but well I don't want somebody else will
have to find a way to do it but you know
one thing we've seen along the way you
know you know we've seen you in a couple
different places sort of expressing your
opinion on film vegetables you know and
your take on that sort of like as these
filmmakers you know or as a filmmaker
as you finish the film are our film
festivals would you say that's the first
destination for a lot of these smaller
films is that where a lot of filmmakers
should be directing their energy when
they complete a film and I get I guess
that's part one and then I'll come back
with part yeah after that I mean I'm
highly critical of film festivals then
it's not really a secret um if you can
get your film into a bigger festival
then you should definitely do it because
it opens more doors probably than you
can otherwise but if you're going to be
shelling out 50 bucks a pop to try to
get into small festivals and have a ten
percent success rate which i think is
about normal then I mean I'm not
convinced that's a good model at all I
mean it just strikes me as throwing good
money after bad um you know I was
talking to somebody i think was raw
spoon and i said i don't see how a lot
of film festivals the fifty dollars
submission fee is a better value than me
finding someone in that city and giving
them fifty dollars worth of DVD RS of
the movie and just have them hand the
mountain festival you know because any
at least you know you're in and you
might get into a festival not screen 250
people so you know that's just that's a
lot of money out of your budget that
should be on screen or should be
somewhere else that you're just and I
think you know I think film festivals
there's some there's notable exceptions
like Flyway and the New Mexico one but I
think a lot of film festivals just view
filmmakers as a revenue stream and they
don't care one iota about the filmmakers
but you know if all of those filmmakers
we just stopped paying submission fees
then they would have to figure out
something else to do now would have to
find that money somewhere else make you
going oh we can't survive without
sufficient fees and I go well that's not
really my problem that's really your
problem you know I already raised my
money from my movie I'm not raising
money to fund your film festival that's
kind of ridiculous you know and in that
vein I mean these productions that's
wrong you know have you gotten a
discussion with the filmmakers I mean
are a lot of these filmmakers a lot of
these sets you've been on
they planning on going the festal rod I
mean what are they talking about are
they even thinking about distribution in
the prodigy some of them are ya some of
them are thinking about self
distribution and going online Sean Sean
and I were talking about that yesterday
because he's film screening tonight over
at the red vic so if you're in san
francisco and this goes online before
then then by all means go go through the
annual um but i think he's thinking of
just skipping the festival circuit so
the most part i mean we skips the
festival circuit for my first feature i
don't really miss it I didn't really
miss it that much I just didn't get to
meet the people i wish i had met but I
saved a lot of money in the process and
then we understand that you had the
comments section disabled from your
posts on filmmaker magazine can you tell
us your reasons for doing oh no I didn't
do that you didn't okay oh I had nothing
to do with that my just saw it on the ID
Assad and today I thought was funny and
the sudden there was all Scott huh and
you know what's at the heart of that do
you know why he might have done that um
he mentioned it on twitter is being kind
of a flame war and i think he just
figured it was it's not being productive
okay is my guess I mean I don't think
he's trying to quell dissent or anything
like that I just think it was just not
against my flying heard the rumors going
around in circles and so it wasn't
really there's no point to it being
there yeah I always say you know cuz i
don't i don't allow anonymous comments
on my blog and i always tell people like
you're going to welcome to get journal
blog and talk about me all you want and
you know no one's going to stop you it's
not really censorship you can still talk
about somebody you just you know i'm
just talking to waste my time with it
and that's I mean I imagine that's part
of it so what's on deck for you from
here mom what do you have planned while
trying to get to New York which is what
I was trying to figure out today because
my buddy Brian Kaz mark is filming his
first feature in New York right now but
getting from New York december from San
Francisco to New York's not exactly
cheap we're trying to keep the budget
you know under control um also he
lost his apartment because when I'm in
New York I'd only stay with him he lost
his apartment also an apartment and they
sold building or something and so he's
sleeping on couches now while he's
trying to direct his future his first
feature so he doesn't really have a
place for me to stay anyway so it's kind
of complicated no I come back in San
Francisco for sean's ville de starts on
the 5th I think then down to LA per
favore okay I mean we'll certainly keep
us posted as you're gonna swing through
LA you know what's on the opportunity of
each in person it would be fun yeah yeah
it'd be fun you know in it and how are
you holding up Lucas I mean you know
here you are you're you know three to
four months into this I mean if ya are
you gonna be able to get through this
this whole year hopefully if I don't
drive off a cliff but trying to tweet
while I'm driving I think that's
probably part of it um you know I'm good
how has it been on the day-to-day level
you know for people like us on the
outside if it's that is that you know
it's that much easier for us to sort of
like follow your post or follow you from
one films film said to another from one
state to another but when you're really
in the grind I mean you're you're you're
the one that's putting in the many hours
of travel you're the one that's putting
in all these hours on set and on top of
that I mean the amount of press that
you're creating you know the content
that you're creating day and day out um
it's just overwhelming for us sometimes
just to follow well you know I mean you
kind of give out your life on some
levels so a lot of the stuff that takes
up your time when you live somewhere is
gone so there's that benefit um the
thing I didn't really factor in to the
in the beginning was when you finish
like a five-day shoot and everybody goes
home and sleeps for like three days but
then I have to get a car drive 400 miles
to the next one so it's been part of it
is then just trying to work in extra
days off in between shoots or not trying
to overbook myself in terms of things
and I started getting into the habit of
doing
hotel rooms because if I have to go a
distance in a short period of time it's
just really helpful to be able to
absolutely sleep for 10 hours and not
have to talk to anybody and I mean just
getting the wifis been the hardest thing
one of the hardest things in the Wi-Fi
connections because the Wi-Fi like in
Seattle is awful it's really awful life
it's seattle like citywide um but yeah
it's a grind it's it's a little
exhausting you know and it's a little
bit of a lonely existence because you
see all these people but then you're in
and out of town in a couple days so
we'll see how how much holding up in
another three months I guess I've been
the biggest takeaway from all this the
biggest sort of surprised that you
weren't expecting you know positive or
negative what's been I think the biggest
surprise has probably been hella com
well I don't know maybe the most
pleasant surprise is how accommodating
people have been other than cancels
cancellations like people are really
really happy to have me in town once
they decide to have me in town let's say
um I don't buy a lot of drinks well we
go places because people like oh you can
even no no I got your beer I got a guy I
got it so that's one of my surprise um
the grind has been more of a grind than
I thought it might be so and i think i
think i've been doing more content than
i planned on and so I've been trying to
keep that up cuz I don't want a short
anybody on whatever publicity bump they
might get from it didn't have you notice
of you know I mean had they been
appreciative of sort of the publicity
bow that they've gotten yeah I think so
for the most part I think they like cuz
it runs a movie and it runs on film
courage and a film by car everybody
loves to thumb out for articles I sleep
because what co-anchor doesn't want to
see their product yeah or at least on
web page and so I think they're really
like that I heard I read them I read
Matson's quote in the in the filmmaker
article that the worry is of what I
might say when I'm on set because I
don't really have any any filter um just
in general i'm not really a filter
person
they have no real control over my
whatever I write about their production
and I hadn't really thought about that
it's being a concern for the films
because I know that I'm because I know
internally that i'm not going to do a
hatchet job on anybody but they don't
know that because I'm just some guy on
on Twitter you know who raised a bunch
of money and it's going to show up yeah
so I guess maybe that was one of the
that's probably been a pretty big
surprise that I didn't think that would
be a concern of people's you know and it
makes sense if you think about it
because you don't want someone showing
up and then say oz or summary it so
terrible it's gonna be awful mall well
blah but I don't think I've I don't
think I've said that about anybody yet
um I've generally scaled back any
negative comments well I mean that this
has been sort of a great sort of run
through you know a nice check point for
us and it hopefully for ya that are
going to tune in here and we appreciate
you taking time Lucas you know my
pleasure you know yeah we have a um if
you you know cuz gas is a dollar more
gallant than it wasn't we budgeted so if
you go to the web page and you see a
little paypal button that says keep us
on the road that does work so feel free
to click it and throw five bucks in
there or whatever and be greatly
appreciated and then that's a year
without rent or a year without rain a
year without red com a year without rent
com the one of those tune didn't want to
keep Lucas on the road Lucas you know
we're excited about the possibility the
opportunity pot said to meet you I'm
soon yeah in the near future and and
we're gonna hopefully do this again at
the next checkpoint you know guys to see
how you're holding up provided i'm still
a lot keep pushing yeah all right and
that's it you know support is a big
believe Thank You weeks for take your
time up oh you guys are hugely helpful
if you know I think we would be pretty
far up the creek without a paddle
without you guys so you know every every
yeah I can't like express with words how
much we appreciate it you're gonna
support no thank you I told Jake stellar
that means like well yeah
of course big big saw that big shout out
to take 70 yeah absolutely yeah I think
this movie is picture locked actually i
think i heard that that I think no
sanctuary is almost done that's good to
hear that's good to hear no Jay Jake's
working hard yeah mouths words care all
right Thank You Lucas there Spinelli
here without rent appreciate it thank
you thanks guys talk to you later